Just got some blood test results back. Concerned about the alkaline phosphatase and the AST,
they just keep going up. I have been on a new chemo pill for the last three weeks.
I've been a new horrible blocker for four weeks. Not sure if all the work I have done the last
month with these changes needs more time to work. What are your thoughts? I don't know the data
and how fast these new medications may work and how fast if they are working. It's going to change the alkaline phosphatase.
Now, I understand alkaline phosphatase and AST are, can indicate liver congestion, alkaline phosphatase
and but not AST. There's also an indicator of a metastatic bony lytic destruction of bone.
So, if the AST went up this time, it can be an indication and can tie with the alkaline phosphatase
and the phosphatase can be an indication just because of what the chemo might be negatively affecting the liver.
And that's part of what you kind of have to go through if you're going to try a new chemo drug.
I would consider increasing your coffee enemas, increasing duede castorial packs over the liver.
That's what I would suggest to do with that. Both alkaline phosphates and AST were elevated.
I think that it can point to the more the liver issue than the bony issue.
So, I would increase things that are going to help flush the liver and get the liver flushed up.
Make sure you drink your plenty of water. It's a really important thing during the summer months.
We don't want to be suffering from ill effects, dehydration.
And, you know, I think it's, you know, and that could be a major thing.
And then you think it's something other than something as simple as dehydration.
It could be very serious, but it can be simple. It's a simple solution.